you have to take care of yourself and
you have to have Financial stability and
you have to be able to take care of your
family and whatever but once you reach
certain point everything else becomes
about others right it can become about
others because you don't have those
basic needs anymore right so sure once
you can Define what that is I think it's
become you gain a letter a greater
degree of freedom to doing uh things for
others and making an impact rate welcome
to 20 minute leaders just sit back relax
and learn from the leaders of today it's
a journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today I'm with Faisal Hoke an
accomplished entrepreneur senior
executive author thought leader public
speaker and advisor to management teams
and board of directors with more than 25
years of cross-industry success he is
the founder of shudoka next chapter and
other companies they focus on enabling
sustainable and transformational changes
Faisal Hub welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for being here how are
you
doing good thank you for having me
Michael appreciate it thank you very
much for being here hey you hold quite a
few
um different hats uh thought leadership
and a variety of of different
organizations a contributor to a variety
of amazing Publications we're also the
founder and managing partner of ishadoka
which I'm excited to hear more about as
well as founder and chair of next
chapter so a lot of different hats if I
sold tell me a little bit about how you
see
sort of your role in what you're doing
what what are what really are you
excited about
well look I mean uh you know first and
foremost I I'm an entrepreneur right and
I come from the tech space
uh so I have had several iteration of uh
technology entrepreneurship over the
years and uh had uh one or two successes
uh some miserable failures uh and then
along the way uh writing has become a
passion uh so I've written a few books
uh uh you know anything uh from
leadership Innovation entrepreneurship
uh mindfulness and transformation and
technology so so I'm I'm excited about
each of these uh projects I call as I
call them right so
um my company sudoka which is in the
commercial space uh is in the enterprise
software business that works does a lot
of work for the government and in the
commercial sector as well uh next
chapter is a resource organization that
I set up recently after I published the
two books that just came out this year
uh both of the main Wall Street Journal
bestseller uh one it's called lift the
other one is everything connects I'm in
general uh a very optimistic uh person
regardless of whatever happens
um and I saw in your bio that you're
very much involved in uh making you know
the uh wishing I mean making the Wish
Foundation my son is a cancer survivor
uh proceed from my uh you know writing
and stuff goes to uh you know kind of
kind of pledged it to cancer research so
you know I mean I get excited for a lot
of different things but there's a
commercial side to it and there is a
humanity and and non-commercial side to
whatever I do and another thing I love
is travel food and people culture food
people and food this kind of runs in my
brain
as I was sharing with you I've been to
your part of the world and other parts
of the world and people people makes me
excited that that's incredible and how
did how did you get started with with
all this with all this work
um I mean you know I I mean um like you
I I was actually a computer science
Computer Engineering student uh I came
up with a base product uh you know way
back in uh late uh 80s early 90s and uh
that was for financial sector but I
ended up working for fidney Bowes and
Don Bradstreet and after that I
um started building uh these complex
Enterprise software I started my first
company and then it just went from there
um and you know and As I Grew Older you
know that your interests change the way
you want to make an impact change the
kind of people you want to work with
chains uh so last five years uh post my
last last company exit of after I exited
my last company I kind of wanted to work
with our government many U.S governments
I've been doing a lot of work in that
space and the right reading uh you know
I mean this is my sixth or seventh book
so it just keeps jumping along in the
background as passion project
incredible and so even when you're
looking tell me a little bit more about
sudoka and and the next chapter and how
these things intertwine through your
journey sure so so look uh you know when
I started Salon because I was like
almost like eight years ago I wanted to
take a lot of my learning from private
sector uh which I've done in the past
I've worked with a lot of very big
Brands uh like uh ge and and Pepsi and
north of Roman Amex you know Etc and
bring those learning of how to transform
your organization uh to uh uh primarily
for public sector so I've I've developed
this methodology and I teamed up with a
uh
organization called khaki International
which is a federal government uh um you
know a contractor in U.S and I've been
working exclusively with them for our
public sector and I have a piece of
methodology
and a piece of software that allows
organization to assess where they are
and how they move to the next level of
uh um you know optimization and and
modernization utilizing the analytics
that you get uh as a result of utilizing
that software so that's that business uh
next chapter is as I said it's a it's a
recent organization I had a
um you know research theme tank in my
previous slides
um this is kind of a restart of that
um I've kind of started this after I
wrote a lift you know which came out
earlier this year
and um you know uh uh the the uh goal of
next chapter is taking the best practice
Knowledge from various parts of the
world uh in the area of leadership
Innovation and transformation and uh put
them in the form of books and
educational program and uh push it out
to as many people as possible so I've
teamed up with the Fast Company as my
publishing arm uh and then I'm uh you
know for next chapter and and now
developing a series of uh digital
courses that are
um kind of very documentary style uh
teaching uh visual you know very much
follows a visual learning process
um and they're all around you know as
the world has changed because of
pandemic and fourth Industrial
Revolution and climate change and you
know all the misinformation that we see
in the world uh how do you prepare
yourself as Next Generation leaders and
how do you uh you know make an impact in
a very digitized world but but at the
same time be very grounded in
mindfulness empathy and and really you
know caring about others and making an
impact not just
squirrely focus on uh creating value
from making more money so it has kind of
that kind of a back note to whatever
we're doing and and
um so we did couple of uh major research
projects this year and then next year
the next one uh that comes out it's
called reinvent that's our own uh
business transformation but a business
transformation in the era of tech you
know uh digital transformation I mean
you know the digital technology that we
see everywhere and anywhere these days
isn't it wonderful tell me a little bit
about sharing leadership and and
disseminating information and making an
impact that way
um and so
no what does that even what does it
entail and and how do you think through
you know making making the most impact
through
through text documentaries different
asynchronous mechanisms to to help
promote leadership Innovation with this
information look I think if we hope you
know we we can learn from anyone and
everyone right I'm a farm believer of
that and and I I've done exactly that
and from all walks of the world uh be it
all walks of uh of Life uh and some
in-text space some in non-tech space uh
actually my first Mentor was a janitor
in my in my college so so uh you know I
mean I I love to learn from anybody and
everybody
um philosophy Western philosophy
Technologies learning is in my account
I'm in my veins so what I've decided to
do is that you know very early on that
whatever I learned I want to kind of
share that and it has no
um really any any kind of a monetary
goal out of this I'm not a typical
author consultant speaker type that's
where my core role you know is making
um you know a living by by doing that
it's purely from the
um notion of learning and sharing and I
think it's only by sharing uh that we
can impact the Next Generation because
history is a is a great teacher and if
we learn the history we kind of get
prepared for during the present time
that can impact future right so I look
at everything from that angle and I've
been a ferocious reader uh and if you
know try to write as much as I can and
share
um and and that's kind of my way of one
way of contributing aside from you know
uh classical or value creation and then
you know doing philanthropic things or
or whatnot but I think there's no
greater gift than uh you know sharing
and teaching and learning
phenomenal and so
um if you're looking at you know your
own
passion for affecting change and being a
leader you know where do you think that
came from for you I'd love to just
understand this
mind just a little bit better about
where all this motivation and passion
coming from I think you know you you uh
you know we all have some innate uh
abilities and you have to tap into
whatever that ability is based on
whatever that you want to do right so
once you figure that out uh
then you can get passionate about
making an impact in all sorts of ways so
my uh you know passion Drive curiosity
Joy comes from those uh you know the
Triangular effect meaning who I am what
I want to do and whatever am I doing
does it have any kind of impact and by
impact by the way I don't mean that you
have to change the world you know you
can make an impact to one person's life
uh the people that you work with or
people who works for you your family
your community you can make an impact in
whatever small way and that's enough so
I've always looked at things from that
point of view so the ability to make an
impact and have a little spark give
somebody a little spark in their lives
is is give me the greatest choice so
I've been kind of always uh you know
following that kind of path so I'm not I
don't think I ever done anything and
it's maybe a country counter-intuitive
as an entrepreneur is that is it really
going to make money yes you need to make
money uh because you know without money
you can you know you cannot economically
cannot be viable and sustainable but my
goal has never been that if I do this I
want to make x amount of dollar or you
know gain the economic gain and that's
the driver it's been always some sort of
an impact is it going to really have any
impact that will uh you know that will
do somebody some good
right so talk to me about you know
making an impact you know as an as a
sort of an idea for for other leaders
you know if I'm looking at myself as a
you know as a growing leader what are
different ways that I can think about
you know making it making a significant
impact to the work that I do yeah you
touched on on one key concept that you
know making an impact doesn't
necessarily need to me you know right
now trying to change the world which
could you know sway somebody from saying
okay no then I'm not then this is not a
core focus of mine because I'm not
equipped right now to change the world
but you're mentioning but even changing
the person's life is making a huge
impact so what are the different things
from your perspective do young leaders
like myself can can keep in mind as we
go around our positions our days and and
the work that we do to make a strong
impact
look I mean you can Define impact the
multitudes away and then you know as you
gain experience and you have more
resources and both from your knowledge
and context and otherwise you can make
different kind of impacts so One impact
is obviously you know whatever you can
do as a person at that particular moment
uh in front of like you and I of this
conversation may actually impact
somebody right that is an impact right
and it will last beyond this momentary
conversation that we're having right so
that's one kind of impact if you come up
with a product that has the ability to
change somebody's uh you know a not
somebody but a large community is uh the
way we they will live or the way they
work or the way they learn or where they
um you know enhance their uh uh
livelihood uh if you can come up with a
product or a service that is also an
impact right so you can take on many
different uh you know ways of impact
creation uh if you make a lot of money
and you donate to charity uh you know
that could survive somebody's lives
right that's also an impact so I don't
think there's one definition of impact
there's many ways to make an impact and
it's not one is better than other it's
the impact is an impact and it's solely
driven by your uh goals your aspiration
and your ability and I don't think you
can measure that just like you know
um you know the best way to improve is
measuring yourself against yourself I
think measuring impact is have you done
your best to do some good you know
that's how I look at impact
right measuring yourself and when how
good what what good you're doing
um and then keeping that as a relative
measure not necessarily and not
necessarily with others as you're
writing you know you write a lot in some
of the you know really the inspiring
part of your journey that that really
touched me was how much content you put
out there and the thoughts he put down
what's been most useful for you as he's
been successfully writing a lot of these
ideas and disseminating this information
because it requires quite a bit of
diligence to to do it so thoughtfully
and so rigorously hey look how many you
know when you do that I've actually read
an article that's why writing is so
important I think when you arrived it
also helps you to kind of frame your
thought process and what is it that you
want to do and how you want to do it uh
where do you want to do it so there's a
there's a reverse impact on you if you
write right and and so so uh and you
know and and if you think from a purely
commercial point of view entrepreneurial
point of view uh entrepreneurial point
of view you know writing allows you to
build a brand and it gives you a
following a bit easier to talk to people
and easier to kind of establish yourself
as a as a as a leader whatever field
that you're you may be in uh but I mean
it it really gives you there's a huge
impact on yourself it allows you to
connect your past with your present and
your future and allows you to kind of
learn who you are and what is it that
you can do with the capabilities that
you may have uh developed as time goes
on
right and so as you continue with your
journey what what is what is your vision
today if you're looking down the line so
you know if you ask me this uh when I
was in my 20s I would give you one
answer uh now that I'm what's in my uh
50s you know early 50s and my answer is
very different I I'm whatever I'm doing
is purely from a uh you know yes I need
to make a living but it's purely driven
by uh whatever am I doing does it have
any meaning to anybody so if I'm writing
something is it gonna make any
difference to somebody if they're at it
if I'm building a product is it gonna
make an organization better than what
they are today so it's purely given from
that point of view I don't have a
particular goal uh per se as I had in my
20s when I said look look I'll call
myself successful when my company
becomes a 30 million dollar company or a
100 million dollar company it's I don't
have that kind of aspiration person
anymore
wow okay well it's definitely it sounds
like a something that
hugely relevant for for so many people
you know young people that just like
myself are listening to this are you
know we're thinking as what are our
goals and what are our Inspirations and
I'm gonna leave with go ahead yeah I
mean my last word about all this is that
look you have to uh take care of
yourself and you have to have Financial
stability and you have to be able to
take care of your family and whatever
but once you reach certain point
everything else becomes about others
right it can become about others because
you don't have those basic needs anymore
right so sure once you can Define what
that is I think it's become you gain a
letter a greater degree of freedom to
doing uh things for others and making
greater impact for the society beyond
beyond your so 100 I think that it's all
already pretty common knowledge you know
then the different studies that show
that once you've reached a certain
certain salary or certain compensation I
remember the exact number maybe was
eighty thousand dollars a year or
something it obviously it depends on
your personal constellation but there is
a certain threshold which is
traditionally lower than what the
average you know tenacious person would
imagine
their aspirations should be financially
where after that point your happiness
levels don't actually necessarily go up
in correlation with more money and
fulfillment comes perhaps from Impact
with others so it's so I can definitely
I can definitely see what you're talking
about and then it sounds like if we all
shared this this Collective vision and
this Collective understanding then that
a lot of things would be better off
because we would everybody would be much
more involved with the community and and
create sort of this Ripple and Butterfly
Effect and if I saw I really want to
appreciate everyone thank you and I
appreciate you coming thank you for on
this podcast I it was it was really
fantastic and I really look forward to
sharing this with friends and family so
thank you very much thank you for having
me Michael appreciate it very much